Our Uzbillahi mina Shaytan Allah Ina regime Bismillahur Rahmanur Rahim Allahumma Salli Allah Sayyidina Muhammadin Wa Ala Ali Sayyidina Muhammadin Kamasallaytawa Salamta Wa Baraktaw Rahimta Wa Tarahamta Allah Ibrahim Wa Ala Ali Ibrahim Fila Alamina Inna Kahamidu Majid Rabbish Rahli Sadri Wa Yasserli Amri Wahlul Rukdata Millisani of Kahu Kauli
Assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu In the previous session, we did a linguistic study of this word al-hamd.
We learned that it is a combination of sincere praise and unconditional gratitude that is owed to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for His constant, relentless,
never-ending Rubuwiyah over His Alameen that He created for us.
And then it's not just Hamd but rather it is Alhamd which means the ultimate praise and it means the absolute gratitude belongs to Him by virtue of Him being our Rabb.
So now the Surah continues and He says Ar-Rahman Ar-Raheem
the Abundantly Merciful and the Consistently Merciful .
We've looked at this word in great detail in one of the previous sessions so I'm not going to go into the meanings of it linguistically or otherwise so much but rather today I want to explore some of the examples of his Rahma but just a quick word on Rahma itself is you know generally we know that it means mercy
But it is actually a type of mercy that brings two things together.
Rahma is the type of love, the type of mercy that actually brings two things together in a way such that the principles of Rabubiya can be applied to that thing.
right and this is why the womb of a mother is called a Rahm because it brings the baby the fetus and the mother together so the mother can nurture it so that she can shower her love over this fetus so that she can help sustain the fetus and then make it grow so the word Rahma is so powerful that
you know, our general understanding of these words like mercy, you know, they fall short in really capturing its essence.
So now in this next verse, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, he highlights his rahmah by dedicating an entire verse just to mention the quality of his rabul biyya.
So what according to him is the essence or the defining attribute of his rabul biyya?
It is His Rahma.
It is His Raham, His mercy, His love, His care, His concern that manifests through His abundance in His Rahmaniyya and His consistency through His Rahiniyya.
And this is why when we look around us, when we study this 'alam,
we find this one thread of Rahma flowing through the entire fabric of his aalam.
It is this glue that lovingly holds this aalam together.
It's that magical magnetic force that just naturally pulls us towards Allah Subhanahu wa Ta'ala and it keeps us connected with our Master.
And so just to put this concept in visual terms,
You can imagine Rahma as this gravitational field, this force of love that pulls us towards Him.
And what we experience from that pull is our Hamd, our ultimate praise and our absolute gratitude that is owed to this magnificent, this abundantly and consistently merciful Rabb of this Alameen, the Ar-Rahman and the Ar-Rahim.
Now, if you look at the gratitude aspect or the gratitude component of Al-Hamd, if we just focus on this one aspect of Shukr, what is the reality of Shukr?
What is the manifestation of sincere gratitude?
It's Taqwa, right?
It is this constant awareness of Allah's presence.
It is the constant recognition and awareness of His blessings.
And this is a very high station.
This type of shukr, it holds a very lofty maqaam and not everyone is truly capable of achieving these high ranks of shukr.
And this is why Allah says in the Quran, Wa kaleerun min ibadi ash-shakur.
Very very few of My servants are truly shakur.
The Shakur is very different from the Shakir.
The Shakir, the grateful, is the one who is grateful for Allah's blessings.
But the Shakur, he's the one who's grateful for calamities and tribulations also, not just blessings.
He actually feels gratitude when horrible things happen to him.
Because most people at best, they'll become patient or resigned.
but the Shakur they actually say Alhamdulillah as they are experiencing these calamities because the Shakur they know that Allah only does good for the believers right there's a Hadith in which Rasulullah said aajaban li amr al-mu'min fa innahu amruhu lahu kulluhu khair how wondrous is the affair of the believer
His affair, all of it is good.
So if you're a true believer, then it's all good.
And that's why if you really do believe, you enter into the state of constant gratitude, even for the tribulations.
It's always Alhamdulillah.
And always a good thing to remember is what Ibn Abbas radiAllahu said, that no matter how bad it is,
it could always be worse and there are people like that there are even in the non-muslim community you'll find people like that you know they always look at the good side well it could be worse think about this you know count your blessing so there are people that just naturally instinctively have this understanding now in this verse Allah says he is a Rabb that is Ar-Rahman and Ar-Rahim
How does His Rahma manifest in our lives?
Today I just want to focus on how His love presents itself in our lives.
How does Allah demonstrate His love for us?
Through His blessings, right?
Through His gifts, His nirma.
When I as a parent, when I want to demonstrate my love for my children, how do I do that?
By bestowing gifts upon them, right?
Valuable, desirable, beneficial gifts.
Gifts that the child understands that he or she could not attain by their own efforts.
Now think about the blessings, the gifts that Allah has bestowed upon all of us.
Incredible gifts, infinite gifts.
If you attempt to enumerate the blessings of Allah, you will never be able to enumerate them.
Gifts that are not only impossible to count their value is just impossible to measure.
Just look at one single nyama.
Look at the nyama, for instance, of the eye.
That is just one nyama, sight.
First of all, think about this, blinking.
Just think about blinking.
You don't even notice that you blink.
Now, if you didn't blink, have you ever seen pictures of Aristotle, Onassis?
you know when he got really old the richest man one of the richest men in the world he owned his own private fleet of ships he had to use band-aids to hold up his eyelids because he lost the function of the muscle that returns the eyelid and his eyelids just dropped all the time so he used band-aids to hold them up but then he had to put drops in his eyes all the time
Because if your eyelids don't close, they get dry and you start getting dust in them.
Because one of the things that blinking does is it brings the dust back down.
You see, they're like windshield wipers, right?
They bring the dust down and then what happens is that the dust, it just moves to the side and accumulates in the corners of the eye.
So when you wipe your eyes, you'll get some of that dust out of the eye.
And you don't even think about that.
That's just one part of the eye.
But then if you think about the intricate network of these nerves behind the eye and the myelination of that sheath, the fact that there's this constant synaptic responses
The fact that there's neural transmission, because that breaks down for some people, right?
They go blind, they lose the function of the sight.
I mean, we don't think about all of this.
Think about the electric work that goes in the function of an eye.
Colors, just think about colors.
Allah could have made everything black and white, right?
Look at all the subtle colors that he put in this world that we can experience.
Our eyes can experience an incredible variety of colors.
I mean that's nirma.
Then look how you know how some of these colors they just give you pleasure in just seeing them.
You don't even think about it.
Today we know that there's vibration
If you look at color, there are seven colors.
All colors go down to seven primary colors.
I think in color theory they go down to three, but basically everybody agrees that there are seven colors in a spectrum.
If you look at visible light, each one of these colors has an effect upon the soul, right?
Red has a certain vibrational resonance.
It's a lower resonance than violet.
Violet is at the high spectrum, red is at the low spectrum.
Red, when you see the color red, it stimulates you.
You don't even know that.
They know that now in color theory because, you know, all the study that's been done on people, that if you put them in red rooms, it has a different effect on them than if you put them in blue rooms.
It'll actually change their moods because these colors have a resonance.
there's an electromagnetic radiation and it's all having a psychological effect on us and we don't even know it now the thing about the world if you go out and look at green green will make you feel good right that's why people love to look at grass they love to visit these gardens they love to look at trees
you know it has a Yunaish as the Arabs would say yeah it's called Rabiyah spring this is why we say in our prayers that Allah make the recital of Quran the spring of my heart Allahummajal Qur'ana Rabiyahaqalbi what does that mean because Rabiyah is that thing which brings your heart back to life because spring
brings your whole being back to life.
People start feeling good.
People get this thing, they call it SAD, Seasonal Affective Disorder, SAD.
There are people who get depressed in the wintertime.
It's an actual psychological state.
But then spring comes around and they forget how depressed they were in the winter.
They start feeling wonderful.
Why are they feeling wonderful now?
Green.
You see, the color starts changing.
There's photosynthesis that's happening.
All this chlorophyll is starting to come back to life.
Flowers start blooming again.
Flowers.
Look at the flowers.
I mean, what is that?
A flower?
Why do people like smelling a flower?
That's another name of scent.
Just the sight of a beautiful flower.
Just the sight, right?
Beauty.
When the eye looks at something beautiful, why do we all respond the same way?
When you see something beautiful, and most people, we all share a common taste in beauty, when we see something beautiful, we're attracted to it, right?
There's an attraction.
Why?
it's because beauty is an attribute of God and what you're seeing in the Alam is a reflection of that divine attribute of your Rabb so you're essentially attracted to the divine but you think you're being attracted to the flower no it's the beauty of the divine manifesting through the flower that is real attraction
Real attraction is not in this ephemeral beauty that fades away.
It's the manifestation of the divine in creation that's the real attraction.
But we don't realize that.
So there are all these things about the eye that we just don't think about.
I mean look at the eyelashes, the eyebrows.
They're serving a purpose, right?
Eyelashes serve a purpose.
I mean, when anything comes near our eye, we instinctively close our eyelids to protect the eye.
I mean, that's just amazing.
So there are all these things about just the eye that if we really start thinking about it, I mean, look at the abundance in just the eye, the abundance in the ni'amah of the eye.
Just look at the Rahmaniya of this Rab.
with one single gift.
And that's based on what we just know so far.
There must be so many blessings that we don't even know about yet.
Subhanallah.
What about light?
Right?
The external factor that makes sight possible, that makes the eye useful, that makes the eye functional.
which in turn makes people happy or depressed.
Why do people get depressed?
You know, one of the reasons they think is because the serotonin level as they drop, which is the key hormone in making us feel happy.
That's what they call serotonin.
They call it the happy hormone, right?
And one of its factors of release is based on light.
So you're taking in light during the day and you're feeling good and happy and cheerful and you don't even think about it.
There are all these hormones that are related to melatonin.
That's based on light, right?
Melatonin is what makes us sleepy.
That's why people that are constantly in artificial light, they have difficulty sleeping.
But the eye is what's doing all of that, right?
The eye is dictating.
That's why we get tired.
It's all based on the eye.
So even our sleep patterns are being affected by the human eye.
And we don't even realize that.
When we feel awake, when we feel drowsy, it's all the result of the eye.
And this is just the eye alone.
We cannot even enumerate all the blessings of the eye, which is one niyama.
This is just niyama tul ayin that we're talking about here.
We cannot even enumerate the blessings of this one organ.
There are untold, infinite blessings in it.
And it's just one nirma.
Allahu Akbar.
So the Shakur is the one who is constantly experiencing the state of gratitude, its presence and the lack of it.
But this comes from this absolute certainty and this is a maqam, this is a station that is related to ridaa, which is complete contentment with Allah Subhanahu wa Ta'ala.
It's a state of muhabba.
It's a state of this intense love because once you fall in love, you just cannot see anything else.
I mean, there's this incredible beauty of love.
You know, when you're in love, you can't see false, right?
Even when they do exist, you just can't see them.
If you love Laila and anybody tells you, you know, Laila did this or she did that, you get angry.
Why?
What?
Laila would never do that.
No, no, no.
I saw Laila did this.
You're lying.
You're a liar.
Laila would never do that.
Why?
Because he's in love with Laila.
No matter what you say about Laila, he's not going to believe you.
You know, that's real love.
People don't even know that type of love anymore.
So if you're in love with Allah, he just cannot do anything that would harm you or hurt you.
Impossible, nothing, because you'll say it's me.
you see I did it to myself Allah didn't do that Allah would never do that I did that to myself or that Allah is doing it because you know like the father that punishes the child you see I mean you see a father punishing the child the father loves the child why is he punishing it because he knows that in that punishment is benefit for the child he's disciplining the child right
He's bringing the child back on the right track.
Through that punishment, he's reminding the child of something worse.
You know, if I see my son putting his hand in the fire, I'll slap his hand.
Why am I doing that?
Because I want him to taste a light pain in order to avoid a much greater pain, you see?
Because I know that the pain of this slap is nothing compared to the pain of the flame.
And when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gives us a tribulation, those are nothing compared to Hellfire.
Nothing.
So if Allah is purifying us to prevent us from doing something that He doesn't want us to do, then the Shakoo realizes that, that this tribulation is the love of His Creator for Him.
You know, the Prophet , he once saw a mother nursing her child.
You know, and this is a man, as they say, you know, the man of Allah takes discernment from everything, right?
He takes ibrah, a discernment, a lesson from everything.
His glance is discernment and his speech is wisdom.
So, there's always a reason why he speaks.
So, the Prophet , he once saw a woman nursing her child, and he said to his Sahaba, Do you think that this woman would throw her child into the Hellfire?
And they said, La wallahi ya Asulallah.
She would never do that.
He said, Allah has more mercy for His servants than this woman has for her child.
Allahu arhamu bi ibaadihi min haadihil um li waladiha Allah has more mercy for His servants than this woman has for her child.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, you know, in Surah Al-Sarah, when he talked about his Prophet Nu alaihis salam, he said, Innahu kaana abdan shakua Indeed, he was a grateful slave because of
the amount of da'wah that he did you know people today they get fed up after a week of da'wah they say you know they give advice two times three times and that's it oh you know I give up these people never listen I mean this is 950 years of doing what Allah asked him to do that's a Shakur and one of the things mentioned in Seerah is that Nu AS he never once
went to relieve himself, except that he came back saying, Alhamdulillah illathi adhiba anni al azha.
Praise and gratitude be to the one who removed this harm from me.
Even just having shukr for something like relieving himself.
Because what a blessing that is!
right I mean think about you know I don't know if you've ever read these stories of Bahlol as kids we used to read them and there's this one story of Bahlol in which he went to visit Harun Rashid the palace of Harun Rashid who was a king at that time and he asked Harun Rashid you know would you like anything and Harun said bring me back a glass of water so they brought him water as he was about to drink it Bahlol asked if you will refuse this water right
you were dying of thirst but you were refused this water what would you give for this water and he said I would give half of my kingdom for it if I couldn't have it and then Bahalol said if you drank this water and then you couldn't release it what would you give to release it he said I'd give the rest of my kingdom so Bahalol asked then what is the worth of your kingdom that is not worth
a cup of water or the release of it as urine in other words what do you really possess you know if it all this kingdom that you possess it doesn't even equal a cup of water or the release of it so think of that the blessing of just eating drinking and digesting it I mean you don't have to tell your hydrochloric acid to be released you don't have to
push any buttons here, right?
You eat something and if it's protein, then it just breaks down into amino acids and your body then reassembles them as muscle tissue.
If it's fat, it breaks down into fatty acids, then your body reassembles them.
If it's carbs, it breaks them down, takes them to the brain, produces energy, right?
If you have extra, then insulin is released, takes it to the liver, stores it as glycogen.
so that when later on you're out of energy the liver can release that glycogen break it down for you and produce energy you don't have to do any of this you don't have to tell the body to do any of this and yet it's all doing that for us Allahu Akbar I mean that's what how to be grateful for the blessings of Allah Islam is all about being grateful to Allah that's what Islam is
We just, just the simplest of things.
Right now, we're all at 98.6 degrees.
Who do you think is maintaining our bodies at 98.6 right now?
Seriously, who's maintaining that?
You know, right now, I could have a fever and I could be shivering.
If I was sick right now, right?
But if I was sick right now,
even though it's a moderate temperature in the room I could be shivering I could be feeling cold and it wouldn't even be cold if I had a fever I would be boiling up right now in a moderate climate you'd all be fine but if I had a fever I would you know want to take off all my clothes and I'd be all hot and sweaty think about that Allah is keeping us all at 98.6
Even if it's 100 degrees outside, our bodies are releasing fluid as sweat in order to maintain this 98.6 on average.
Even if it's 100 degrees outside, why don't we boil up to 100 degrees?
What created that inner thermostat that keeps us all at this balance?
If it's cold out, why don't we all drop down and freeze?
Because we would if, you know, if we go out in ice cold temperatures long enough, we'll freeze.
But for a period of time, we won't.
We'll all stay at 98.6.
Why?
Allahu Akbar.
We go swimming in cold water and our temperature maintains itself.
This is all from Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala.
All manifestation of the Rahmaniya and the Rahimiya of our Rab.
and the Shakur is constantly aware of the abundance of these blessings of Rahman but then they also look at those that are less fortunate than them in their worldly affairs they use that as a resource to draw even more gratitude right there's a Hadith of Rasulullah in which he said about this dunya
that you should always look at people who are less fortunate than you are in Dunya because you'll always feel grateful there's always people who are less fortunate than you are today I guarantee you no matter how miserable you think you are you'll always find people in a in much more misery than you are right now so you say Alhamdulillah
I mean if you don't have a lot of money you know in this country the United States or even most of us living in Pakistan and India we're considered well off we're considered you know decently rich in biblical times to put a jar of honey on your table was considered a sign of immense wealth think about that a jar of honey on your table was a sign of great wealth
Really.
The majority of people living in America today would be considered royalty in previous times.
The houses that we live in, they would be considered palaces.
The facilities that we have, this idea of having running water, just running water.
The fact that you can take a hot shower just by turning a knob, people don't even think about this.
There are places today in this world, wallahi, there are women who have the sole job of bringing water every day.
It takes some about two hours to go get the water.
It takes about an hour to fill up, you know, these kirbah, what they call.
Loaded on the back of donkeys in these villages and then two hours to come back home.
Five hours, five hours every day just to bring drinking water to their village and that's their entire life.
Can you imagine what they must feel when they drink water?
What do you think they would say after all that five hours of hard work when they take that first step?
What do you think they say?
Alhamdulillah.
That water, it's brown.
Most of them have kidney problems.
Most of them have urinary problems because of the sediment in that water.
People have forgotten this.
We could have been born in that village.
You and I could have been born in that village, drinking that brown water, having those kidney problems.
I mean, we never think about these things, do we?
Just think about the blessings, the na'ma of this house that we live in.
Think about the na'ma of water, the na'ma of food on our table, the na'ma of clothes to cover up our nakedness, to keep us warm.
The ni'amah of a bed.
The ni'amah of just being healthy.
I mean ni'amatul aafiya that you got up in the morning and you weren't sick.
Think of how many people got up this morning and they had to empty out a bag that had their urine in it.
A bag that they have to change every hour.
Think of how many people that got up this morning that couldn't go to the toilet or they bled blood.
Think how many people there are with asthma.
They couldn't breathe this morning.
They woke up gasping for air.
Really?
Think about how many people spend their last night coughing.
They couldn't sleep because of this cough.
Really?
That's why, I mean Shukr, showing gratitude to Allah Subhanahu wa Ta'ala, you really have to wonder about our lives, right?
Just the blessings that the Ar-Rahman has bestowed upon us and our complaints, my God! Our constant never-ending complaints against God.
What did I do to deserve this?
What have I done to this?
You exist.
That's enough as a crime, really.
If you really think about this, that's enough as a crime to think that you exist beside Allah .
To think that we share existence with Allah.
We are criminals.
Just for having that thought because la ilaha illallah.
There is nothing worthy of ilahiyya except Allah.
And yet here we are, right, walking around, just thinking, you know, these little contingent creatures living on this insignificant planet, in this insignificant galaxy,
that are totally dependent for every breath at every instant on Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and we think we are independent.
We think we are self-sufficient.
We think we are in control.
If I'm in such a state of heedlessness with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala I'm a criminal.
If I forget Allah for one instant I am a criminal and I stand condemned.
And then anything that happens to me, I deserve it.
Because I've forgotten who Allah is and who I am in relation to that.
Oh man! What has deluded you about your master?
What has deluded you about your Lord?
Why are you in the state of Uroor?
Total delusion.
Thinking that you don't need me at every instant of your life.
Just to draw your next breath.
Just to have your next heartbeat.
I mean heartbeat.
What is a heartbeat?
An electric impulse.
Who's activating it?
It's Allah Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
You think it's your brain.
It's not your brain.
Your brain is not doing that.
They don't even know what's doing it.
I mean, you can cut all your nerves to the brain and the heart will still beat, right?
What makes the heart beat?
And yet, here we are, these insignificant creatures complaining about Allah , judging him for his faults.
That's a crime.
or we sit on our high horses, you know, right next to Him judging others.
Our Ulama, I mean just looking down upon others based on their knowledge that Allah has bestowed them with.
That's not why Allah gave you that knowledge to look down on others.
He created us all as brothers to embrace each other.
See, there's two ways to embracing, right?
There's the embrace of an equal
And then there is the embrace of the superior.
Did you ever think about that?
What's the embrace of an equal?
You embrace somebody who's the same as you.
If I embrace you, you're my brother.
We have an equal embrace.
We're the same height.
I put my arms around you.
You put your arms around me and we have an embrace.
That's the embrace of an equal.
What's the embrace of a superior to an inferior?
How do you embrace a child?
The child can put his arms around you.
You pick them up, right?
You lift them and you embrace them and you hold them.
See, that's Islam.
That massage, that temperament, the temperament of Islam is to take all these other sects and religions and those who are inferior in knowledge and then just embrace them.
That's the embrace of Allah .
He is so great that He will even allow somebody that denies Him to exist.
I mean, if you want to think about greatness, that is greatness.
That is Rahma.
He'll feed them, He'll nurture them, give them rain, keep their bodies healthy, give them a wife, children that love Him.
Allah does all of that, even though that person denies His very existence.
But all that does is show the greatness of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
You know, there's a story of Ibrahim alaihi salam that one night, it was famous about him that he never ate alone, right Ibrahim alaihi salam?
He always found somebody to eat with.
But one night he couldn't find anybody so he went out looking for someone and then he finally found this man and he brought him home.
And this man was a mushrik.
So before
this man ate his food he blessed it in the name of his idols and when Ibrahim heard that he said you know you can't eat any of my food you're an idol worshiper get out of here so the man left but then Allah revealed to Ibrahim he said Ibrahim I have been feeding him for 40 years
And I've been patient with his idolatry for 40 years.
You couldn't be patient with him for just one meal.
And so, Ibrahim , he went and he found that man, he apologized to him, invited him back to his table.
And the man asked why?
What suddenly changed?
And he told him.
And this man became a Muslim.
That is Islam.
You know.
This ability to embrace everyone.
I mean that's dawah.
What is dawah?
In Arabic, even in Urdu, you say, you know, what is dawah?
What does that word mean?
It's an invitation, isn't it?
Now if I put a gun to your head and I say you're coming to dinner tonight at my house, is that an invitation?
Seriously, is that an invitation?
It's not.
You're not inviting someone, you're forcing them to come.
And you know, there's no compulsion in religion.
An invitation is only valid if you allow the person the possibility of refusing that invitation.
Now, who would allow the person that possibility?
A generous host, right?
Allah has made a house he called it Darus Salaam he invited all of his creation to it and he gave them the option to refuse to come to that house so if people refuse it why are we so fearful of them why are we so afraid of them right see the thing about people you know that when they are ignorant they fear that's what a fundamentalist is that's what an extremist is
It is somebody who's afraid of the other.
He's afraid of having his Iman challenged.
He's so afraid that he won't even allow for the other to exist because he can't.
He's not going to allow that possibility.
He wants them eliminated my way or the highway.
And we have this in our own community at our own levels, right?
If you're not going to follow what I'm saying, that's it.
And that's really a disease.
That's not Islam.
Islam is the only religion that's ever allowed other religions, other ideologies to exist side by side with it because it creates this environment of invitation.
It allows the other people to experience something different and then be attracted to it.
But because we present this harshness in our behaviors and then call it Islam, no wonder people are getting turned off from Islam in multitudes.
Because we have no care about a fellow human being.
We don't look at the other person as a human being.
We look at them as either Muslim, non-Muslim, Christian, Jew, believer, non-believer, in agreement with me, in disagreement with me, my enemy, right?
There's no...
One of the great scholars of Islam, he said that the door that he came to his Lord through was Taazim al-Mahluqat.
exalting the creation of Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala.
He said, ...
I never saw a scholar except I exalted him because of the knowledge that he was carrying.
But then it got to a point where
Mara aytumu'minan au Musliman mahmakaanahaluhu illah azzamtahu li intisabihil 'ubu diyatillah I never saw a believer or a Muslim man, no matter what his state was, but I exalted him just for being a servant of Allah.
Just for attempting to submit to Allah.
But then he said that I didn't see anyone, even the non-Muslims,
illa azzam tahu li annahu mahallal iradatillahi subhana wa ta'ala haisu awjaduhu bi qawlihi kun fayakun Except that I never saw anyone, anything in this universe except that I exalted it because through his existence, I saw the will of the divine manifesting before my eyes.
so he said I never saw a rock or a tree or anything or anyone except that I saw it as a manifestation of the divine will it was God that put that thing there that's what he was acknowledging and then he said the one who exalts the the sanctified things of Allah he is the one who is most loved by Allah
And what is more sanctified in this Alam than the creation of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala?
These things that Allah has created as His Tajalli, right?
His divine manifestations that invite us all to marvel over it, praise it.
They draw out from us the praise component of this Hamd.
I mean, if you look at
If you look at people, right?
When you see people who can do something slightly amazing, you see this beautiful singer singing a song in his or her beautiful voice or playing an instrument in a concert.
What do people do?
They just clap, right?
They just stand up, whistle and clap.
They do all these things.
They give this artist a standing ovation.
to praise him or her because of what's happening in their hearts they just see something extraordinary and they want to praise it they cannot help themselves because they just saw something that affected their soul so when they see somebody who mastered the piano for instance you know who got up and played some extraordinary piece of Beethoven they just stand up and they clap and they clap and they clap
And the point is to say what an extraordinary thing you've just done before my eyes, right?
It was truly incredible.
That's what they feel like doing because they find it so amazing.
And yet we're here in this incredible existence, this theater of amazing creations, stars in the heavens,
galaxies of them.
You know, we've got Hubble telescopes that look into the furthest corners of the universe, into this massive expansiveness.
We have flowers that bloom before our eyes that demonstrate these beautiful colors, this incredible scent.
We watch flowers that move across as the sun moves in the sky, you know, flowers that follow the sun.
There are, the Arabs call them Abadashams, you know, slaves of the sun.
We have animals that do the most extraordinary things.
Elephants that can carry these extraordinary weight on their backs.
But then ants, little tiny ants, the most extraordinary in their creation that they can carry many times their own weight.
All of these things are happening right before our eyes.
We have women with the fetus developing in their wombs.
You know, mitotic cell division happening at these rapid rates.
All of these things happening everywhere, constantly within us, outside of us.
And we don't feel compelled to give Allah a standing ovation.
To stand before Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala at least five times a day and say Allahu Akbar, Allahu Akbar, Allahu Akbar.
really to stand in ovation before our master like people stand before some poor soul who has perfected some little trick on a musical instrument can just pipe out a tune and and we're so compelled to jump up out of our seats and clap and you know Bravo Bravo and we can just get up to praise the master of this world the Rahman and the Rahim and just say Allahu Akbar I mean
Really, what is wrong with us?
What has deluded us?
What has taken us away from the praise and the gratitude of our master?
I just am so guilty of all of this.
It's so hard to even admit and acknowledge this, but we're all in the same boat of ingratitude and
Our Prophet constantly went into Sajdah out of gratitude and praise for every little thing.
He saw an eclipse.
He went and gave God an ovation.
He prayed.
He stood up and, you know, he prayed, went into Sajdah as a testimony that he was witnessing something incredible.
He was witnessing a reminder of the Rahmani and the Rahiniya of his Rabb.
Everything, every instant was a reminder for him.
And yet here we are blessed beyond measures.
May Allah strengthen our hearts to witness and to experience and give us this ability to just marvel over the blessings of His Rahmaniyya and His Rahimiyya because may He help us experience the joy of true and sincere praise and unconditional gratitude for not only everything that He has done for us but
also for what he has withheld from us for not only the joy in our lives but also for the grief and the sorrows that humble us that reminds us that that breaks our intoxication of this world that sobers us that pulls us off our high horses and just throws us down on the floor
Alhamdulillahi Rabil Alameen was salatu was salam ala Rasulahi Said al Muhammadin Khatim al Nabeen was Said al Mursaleen walaqi wasi Ali Nabi Taliba Shrafil was sayeen.